this video is about everything you need
to know about the t-test
after this video you know what a t-test
is and when you use it what types of
t-tests there are what the hypotheses
and the assumptions are how a t-test is
calculated and how you interpret the
results
let's start with the first question what
is a t-test the t-test is a statistical
test procedure
and what does the t-test do the t-test
analyzes whether there is a significant
difference between the means of two
groups for example the two groups may be
patients who received one's drug a and
once drug B we would now like to know if
there is a difference in blood pressure
between these two groups
now there are three different types of
t-tests the one sample t-test the
independent samples t-test and the
paired samples t-test
when do we use a one sample t-test we
use the one sample t-test when we want
to compare the mean of a sample with a
known reference mean example a chocolate
bar manufacturer claims that it's
chocolate bars weigh an average of 50
grams
to check this we take a sample of 30
bars and weigh them the mean value of
this sample is 48 grams now we can use a
one sample t-test to check if the mean
of 48 grams is significantly different
from the claimed 50 grams when do we use
the independent samples t-test
we use the t-test for independent
samples when we want to compare the
means of two independent groups or
samples we want to know if there is a
significant difference between these
means example we would like to compare
the effectiveness of two painkillers we
randomly divide 60 people into two
groups the first group receives track a
and the second group receives track B
using an independent t-test we can now
test whether there is a significant
difference in pain relief between the
two drugs when we use the pair samples
t-test we use the paired samples t-test
to compare the means of two dependent
groups example we want to know how
effective a diet is to do this we weigh
30 people before the diet and then weigh
exactly the same people after the diet
now we can look at the difference in
weight between before and after for each
subject we can now use a paired samples
t-test to test whether there is a
significant difference
in a paired sample the measurements are
available in pairs the pairs result for
example from repeated measurements with
the same people
independent samples are made up of
people and measurements that are
independent of each other here's an
interesting note the paired samples
t-test is very similar to the one sample
t-test we can also think of the paired
samples t-test as having one sample that
was measured at two different times we
then calculate the difference between
the paired values giving us a value for
one sample the difference is once minus
five once plus two ones minus one and so
on and so forth now we want to test
whether the mean value of the difference
just calculated deviates from a
reference value in this case 0 this is
exactly what the one sample T Test does
what are the assumptions for a t-test of
course we first need a suitable sample
in the one sample t-test we need a
sample and a reference value in the
independent t-test we need two
independent samples and in the case of a
pair T Test a pair sample the variable
for which we want to test whether there
is a difference between the means must
be metric examples of metric variables
are age body weight and income for
example a person's level of education is
not a metric variable
in addition the metric variable must be
normally distributed in all three t-test
variants to learn how to test if your
data is normally distributed watch my
video test for normal distribution
in case of an independent t-test the
variances in the two groups must be
approximately equal you can check
whether the variances are equal using
Levine's test for more information watch
my video on Levine's test so while the
hypotheses of the t-test let's start
with the one sample t-test in the one
sample t-test the null hypothesis is the
sample mean is equal to the given
reference value so there's no difference
and the alternative hypothesis is the
sample mean is not equal to the given
reference value what about the
independent samples t-test in the
independent t-test the null hypothesis
is the mean values in both groups are
the same so there's no difference
between the two groups and the
alternative hypothesis is the mean
values in both groups are not equal so
there is a difference between the two
groups and finally the paired samples
t-test in the pair T Test the null
hypothesis is the mean of the difference
between the pairs is zero and the
alternative hypothesis is the mean of
the difference between the appears is
not zero so now we know what the
hypotheses are before we look at how the
t-test is calculated let us look at an
example of why we actually need a t-test
let's say there is a difference in the
length of study for a bachelor's degree
between men and women in Germany our
population is therefore made up of all
grad weights of a bachelor who have
studied in Germany however as we can
observe the old batch like graduates we
draw a sample that is as representative
as possible we now use the t-test to
test the null hypothesis that there is
no difference in a population if there
is no difference in the population we
will certainly still see a difference in
study duration in the sample it would be
very unlikely that we drew a sample
where the difference would be exactly
zero in simple terms we now want to know
at what difference measured in a sample
we can say that the duration of study of
men and women is significantly different
and this is exactly what the t-test
answers but how do we calculate a t-test
to do this we first calculate the T
value to calculate the T value we need
two values first we need the difference
between the means and then we need the
standard deviation from the mean this is
also known as the standard error in a
one sample t-test we calculate the
difference between the sample mean and
the known reference mean as is the
standard deviation of the collected data
and N is the number of cases s divided
by the square root of n is then the
standard deviation from the mean which
is the standard error in a dependent
samples t-test we simply calculate the
difference between the two sample means
to calculate the standard error we need
the standard deviation and the number of
cases from the first and second sample
depending on whether we can assume equal
or unequal variance for our data there
are different formulas for the standard
error read more about this in our
tutorial on datadeep.net in a paired
sample t-test we only need to calculate
the difference between the paired values
and calculate the mean from that the
standard error is then the same as for a
one sample t-test so what have we
learned so far about the T value no
matter which t-test we calculate the T
value will be greater if we have a
greater difference between the means and
the T value will be smaller if the
difference between the means is smaller
for sure that the T value becomes
smaller when we have a larger dispersion
of the mean so the more scattered the
data the less meaningful a given mean
difference is now we want to use the
t-test to see if we can reject the null
hypothesis or not to do this we can now
use the T value in two ways either we
read the critical T value from a table
or we simply calculate the p-value from
the T value we'll go through both in a
moment but what is the p-value a t-test
always tests the null hypothesis that
there is no difference so first we
assume that there is no difference in
the population when we draw a sample
this sample deviates from the null
hypothesis by a certain amount the
p-value tells us How likely it is that
we would draw a sample that deviates
from the population by the same amount
or more more than a sample we drew thus
the more the sample deviates from the
null hypothesis the smaller the p-value
becomes if this probability is very very
small we can of course ask whether the
null hypothesis holds for the population
perhaps there is a difference but at
what point can we reject the null
hypothesis this border is called the
significance level which is usually set
at five percent so if there is only a
five percent chance that we draw such a
sample or one that is more different
than we have enough evidence to assume
that we reject the null hypothesis and
to put it simple we assume that there is
a difference that the alternative
hypothesis is true now that we know what
the p-value is we can finally look at
how the T value is used to determine
whether or not the null hypothesis is
rejected let's start with the path
through the critical T value which you
can read from a table to do this we
first need a table of critical T values
which we can find on datatap.net under
tutorials and T distribution
let's start with the two-tailed case
we'll briefly look at the one-tailed
case at the end of this video here below
we see the table first we need to decide
what level of significance we want to
use let's choose a significance level of
0.05 or 5 then we look in this column at
1 minus 0.05 which is
0.95 now we need a degrees of freedom in
the one sample t-test and the paired
samples t-test the degrees of freedom
are simply the number of cases -1 so if
we have a sample of 10 people there are
9 degrees of freedom in the independent
sample C test we add the number of
people from both samples and calculate
that -2 because we have two samples note
that the degrees of freedom can be
determined in a different way depending
on whether we assume equal or unequal
variance so if we have a five percent
significance level and 9 degrees of
freedom we get a critical T value of
2.262 now on the one hand we've
calculated a t value with the t-test and
we have the critical T value if our
calculated T value is greater than the
critical T value we reject the null
hypothesis for example suppose we
calculate a t value of 2.5 this value is
greater than
2.262 and therefore the two means are so
different that we can reject the null
hypothesis on the other hand we can also
calculate the p-value for the T value
we've calculated if we enter 2.5 for the
T value and 9 for the degrees of freedom
we get a p-value of C
0.034 the p-value is less than 0.05 and
we therefore reject the null hypothesis
as a control we copy the T value of
2.262 here we get exactly a p-value of
0.05 which is exactly the limit if you
want to calculate a t-test with data tab
you just need to copy your own data into
this table click on hypothesis test and
then select variables of interest for
example if you want to test whether
gender has an effect on income you
simply click on the two variables and
automatically get a t-test calculated
for independent samples
here below you can read the p-value if
you're still unsure about the
interpretation of the results you can
simply click on interpretation in words
a two-tailed t-test for independent
samples equal variances assumed showed
that the difference between female and
male with respect to the dependent
variable salary was not statistically
significant thus the null hypothesis is
retained the final question now is what
is the difference between directed
hypotheses and undirected hypothesis in
the undirected case the alternative
hypothesis is that there is a difference
for example there is a difference
between the salary of men and women in
Germany we don't care who earns more we
just want to know if there is a
difference or not in a directed
hypothesis we are also interested in the
direction of the difference for example
the alternative hypothesis might be that
men earn more than women or women earn
more than men if we look at the T
distribution graphically we can see that
in the two-sided case we have a range on
the left and the range on the right we
want to reject the null hypothesis if we
are either here or there with a five
percent significance level both ranges
have a probability of 2.5 percent
together just five percent if we do a
one-tailed t-test then I'll have is
rejected only if we are in this range or
depending on the direction which we want
to test in that range with a five
percent significance level all five
percent fall within this range
I hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time